hi there Steve Kaufman today I want to
give you a brief introduction very brief
introduction to Japanese I was asked to
do this but one of my to do this in
Chinese from one of my Chinese speaking
viewers so I thought I would do first in
English just to see what I have to say
himself Japanese is perceived as
difficult I don't think Japanese is
difficult the biggest obstacle to my
mind is the writing system you first of
all have to learn the two syllable based
writing systems hiragana and katakana
which are parallel fifty symbols
relatively easy to learn but you also
have to learn at least 2,000 Chinese
characters in order to be able to read
adult call it you know newspapers books
and so forth in the language and as you
know I very much believe in lots of
listening and reading in order to get
used to the language but on the plus
side in Japanese there are no verb
endings to worry about mounting
declensions to worry about once you get
over that initial hurdle it's relatively
straightforward other than the fact that
it's different and you have to get used
to the way it's different you have to
get used to the fact that they have
these little you know column dividers
call them markers column post position
words like I go to Tokyo with you
watashi wa a not that tall with you
anata talked you with you talk you're a
Tokyo to iki mas so you have these
little dividers so you have to get used
to but once you get used to it it's a
pretty good comes and it functions it's
it's it's not that difficult you have to
remember too many things there's only a
few of them it knee Cara and I'm gonna
leave a link here to an excellent
Japanese grammar which covers most of
what you need to know very simply with
no typical useless drills and
unnecessary explanations very much to
the point so check that one out so you
get used to that
you know anata need to you home wall the
old deck designates on as the object
like I'm going to give you a book
Joshua an Anthony for more Oh always
book oh I'll give us give so that's the
first thing you gotta remember the
second thing you have to get used to is
the verbs come at the end so in all of
those sentence that I gave you the verb
came at the end it's difficult to get
used to it's also difficult for Japanese
people who speak English who have a
tendency to say it is a beautiful day
just I think so the just I think comes
at the end
whereas we say I think it's a beautiful
day so in Japanese the verb comes at the
end also in Japanese they have what I
think are very elegant ways of giving
and receiving things so yeah a guru is
to do it for you yep tomorrow is to
again you have to me to do again is to
give more hours to receive so I give the
up day I do give do receive you have to
get used to it
you also have to get used to a lot of
stuff is left out in Japanese and
because it's understood so if I say it
must
it can mean I'm going can mean tomorrow
I start Chema's if I say Hamas Ikki
mascot I mean the car and indicates a
question but you'll notice that the
pronoun is left out and we know from the
context who we're talking about so
there's so many things like that that
are contextual as I say good things come
after so it Donna if we go it could a
show probably go he cannot get it about
nine or nine we have to go and so a lot
of these things you just have to get
used to like and some of the things may
seem at first a little clumsy like we
have to go we cannot eat can
gorillas cannot not a knife like it's
not acceptable not to go means we have
to go so at first these things seem
difficult but they're not difficult in
the sense of trying to remember verb
endings to my mind at least they're
difficult in terms of getting useful
so my recommendation in Japanese is to
first of all invest the time in the
writing system do a lot of reading and
listing that's what I did when I learned
Japanese don't convince yourself that
it's difficult it isn't but like any
language it requires a lot of exposure a
lot of getting used to before you're
comfortable before you can understand it
when you hear it and before you're able
to speak it so that's just touching a
broad brush including that link to that
excellent grammar if there are specific
aspects of Japanese that you would like
me to talk about from the perspective of
my experience I'll be happy to do that
so thank you for listening bye for now